la rivière des roches c'est un véritable
parc de jeux aquatiques grandeur nature
en bas c'était chaud le chic plus haut
ça glisse dans les toboggans et ça saute
dans les bassins c'est michael de run
aventure qui nous accroche guide dans
cette ronde ou stark de la réunion
ouverte à tous de 7 à 77 ans il suffit
juste de savoir nager pour s'y engager
et c'est parti pour deux heures trente
de descente avec sow et toboggan en
toute liberté
devenu c'est l'arrivée des roches donc
levé des roches joli petit fouet qui se
trouve à saint benoît juste après bras
panon ici à la possibilité de pique
en famille tout en restant près
du parking sans marcher
oui
une demi heure ou thuyas basse à la
merde magnifique
bassin avec quelques cas stade des
orgues basaltiques le barrage de
bon bah on a deux trois chaos rocheux à
passer à la main show crapahutant un
petit peu en se mettant à l'eau partant
de masse à la mer
juste un petit peu au-dessous qu'on a
fait c'est trois quatre heures au rocher
on s'est mis un petit peu à l'eau et où
on arrive
sur un toboggan déçu car on se laisse
glisser dedans qui fait cinq six mètres
de vide ce toboggan la cwa libye quand
il fait beau c'est nickel c'est génial
mais dès que la météo des que c'est un
peu nuage et dans le daleo faut faire
très attention faut se méfier
pourquoi parce qu'il ya des endroits où
la pluie tombe pas forcément ici ça
jette dedans ça crée des phénomènes de
crue
donc quand vous êtes là on pique nique
en famille tout ça faut être très
vigilant par rapport à tout ça pas trop
conseillé de rester dans des endroits ok
c voilà plus à l'abri non pour gagner
pour un progrès non mule l'on comprend
un nouveau ring à mahina midi en cause à
la
à mon avis
aux alentours pas un entraîneur
nous avons
côté baisses étaient mon spot de jeu
avec mes copains tout adolescent heureux
c'est là on n'avait pas playstation
c'est là on venait découvrir d'où tu
jadallah nature d'accueil d'oiseaux
des camarades d'école les différents os
vraiment accéder par l'eau pour profiter
de ce genre de décor on voit pas ça
qu'on marche dans les champs de canne à
sucre
les gens y font ils font pas attention
en fait ils ressentent pas le danger
bien conscient d'encadrement la côté de
cela si vous
nous avons trouvé tout cela ça trivia il
ya plein de dangers qui se voit pas à
l'oeil nu comme ça mais voilà
non
il
m